so today we're going to be going to Red
Lobster dressed as a lobster so
obviously anything can happen I don't
really know what's going to happen so
I'm gonna get dressed now I haven't
picked out my name yet
I feel like Lauren no Libby uh you can
just call me Libby oh yes I'm Libby the
lobster Libby I got this on Amazon it's
pretty sweet I haven't tried it on yet a
little wrinkled but under the sea
everything so somebody everything is
always greener in somebody else's lake
everything mmm hello I'm getting
character character here my name's Libby
my name's Libby with my name in Libby
hello hello my name's Libby hello do you
think that do you think Libby should
have an iPhone or Samsung s5 I feel like
she's a real sense on girl nothing not
one oh my god not sponsored but the s5
actually is water resistant up to like
500 meters should you pay me the big
bucks for I'll pay you
oh we have some we have some young boys
caviar why how do you think they feel
about crustaceans y'all boys like
crustaceans you know what don't knows
our things are not right they're all
looking over here - all right can I just
walk out of here look Bulls mighty me
Libby hello
like do I look pretty yeah want a Red
Lobster
can't wait say it one won't go get more
tan look at an injured toe Libby got
hurt yeah so okay
okay you ready Jen look at their look
and I'm real nervous hi is it okay if I
just walk out of here okay thank you
hi it just do close up hand do that and
then okay all right ready
do I have a double chin you can see all
right are you filling yeah I don't know
how did you speakerphone do anything uh
one second please
what do you want do you want something
pot no thanks I'm good
oh that's it please thank you open stole
bucks stop laughing
oh sure thank you sorry movie I'm dying
I can't okay
oh I hope I don't get stabbed you know
no way off me
I'll keep losing more exit cuz I'll kick
in the moves and some force what your
Vista gosh yeah really
okay right of course I do alright I
could never be gluten-free because these
Red Lobster cheesy biscuits I wha Wow
sorry don't have a car oh my goodness oh
yeah little confused cuz where I'm from
we drive on the other side
alright alright guys we're here
Libya's oh she's geared up is this
everything okay like is everything what
can you see like do I look alright the
plan I have any makeup on today cuz I
thought we could I'd be covered but I'm
not that covered all right get in there
yes that's crazy am i calling out do you
work no come here
it's my first time doing here haha are
you kidding come on one of my servers
are back just like listen guys I was
scary but there's a bargain what and
they are just like a walker I have to go
and I ran out oh my god she's smart and
I looked over and I saw her oh that's so
funny
yeah he's running in again oh my god
definitely I make youtube videos this
will be on YouTube
I'm crying okay I'll just do one getting
back up oh my god I'm crying lobster
lobster all right we did it I've got my
girl more cheesy biscuits I or ate one
really quick has got hungry
it's been a long swim here I'm tired
that vine took all my energy favourite
call Washington's office they have my
app you oh yeah all go to place an order
please